alors vous connaissez la terre entière
et je veux faire une interview vous où
ça que je vais vous citer les noms de
jean ah oui c'est terrible ça mais pas
pour vous fâchez pas gagné c'est nous
qui gagnons à vous écouter
alors je me citer des noms de gens et
vous réagissez par exemple louis malle
vous l'avez beaucoup aimé vous l'aimez
toujours touchant vous croyez que vous
avez fait d'abord un ascenseur pour
l'échafaud avec les à main et les amants
à derna fille dix autres films
ensuite on va en parler mais est ce que
vous auriez fait les amants si vous
n'aviez pas été excusés mon amant avec
lui quand même très lentes indique tout
vous n'auriez pas fait vous l'auriez
fait ça n'aurait pas été possible sans
lui et sans moi après vous avez viva
maria où elle a eu un peu des problèmes
parce que peut le dire maintenant il ya
prescription bardot quand même je
faisais un peu chier quoi sinon il n'y a
pas vraiment une langue c'est vrai
qu'elle était un peu chiant ouais mais
c'était vécu en tout cas par mois tout à
fait bien encore vous oui oui mais parce
qu'il y avait tous ces journalistes ou
ses photographes autour et ce qui
comptait pour les médias c'était la
rivalité s'était alors que rivalité il y
en avait absolument pas mais quelquefois
c'était emmerdant attendu 19h45 une
chaleur de plomb c'était pas toujours
alors je demandais de me prévenir quand
même ça va mais c'est difficile
non il lui s'occupait plus d'elle parce
qu'avec vous il savait que c'était réglé
un peu donc de l'indre où la tension
elle quand même temps il ne faisait pas
ce qu'il a à la santé beaucoup plus
fragile il a sentait beaucoup plus
fragile c'est vrai que quelquefois je ne
prenais pas très bien de sa part à lui
orson welles voulait connu en quelle
année assez connu
je débutais de presse que j'ai connu à
la comédie française
ça devait être en 1951 est gelée suivi
toute sa vie de mon époque il a jamais
été très mince il était il était bel
homme et puis j'ai jamais pensé à sa
corpulence
après je me suis pas inquiété un petit
peu inquiété mais c'était à cause de sa
fragilité de sa santé et lorsque je le
sentais malheureux mais j'ai toujours
trouvé beau c'est vrai qu'il n'aimait
pas qu'on le voit mon jeu non il n'y
avait pas savoir qu'un jour le v surpris
en espagne en train de manger
oui on a vu en bleu mais d un cochon de
lait entier qu'il avait devant lui avait
donné une adresse à côté de madrid et
j'y suis allé avec un ami il n'y avait
personne et on vous a proposé
différentes salles une sorte d'auberge
et puis j'ai ouvert une porte et or ce
n'était là j'ai vu qu'il était féru j'ai
fait comme si je n'avais pas vu et un
jour vous a proposé de tout quitter pour
le suivre aux états unis veut pas pas
tout quitter ils voulaient payer le
dédit de la comédie française
bunuel c'est un homme que j'aurais pu
aimer follement s'il avait été un peu
plus jeunes ont marqué son jeune âge
mais je n'ai pas mal gêné lui alors je
dis lui disais que j'aurais aimé qu'il
soit mon père et lui me disait que
j'avais tort parce qu'il aurait été
absolument tyrannie qui n'auraient
sûrement enfermé dans un placard il
n'aurait pas les faveurs du cinéma n'en
sais rien pas un peu comme votre peur
oui mais mon père pendant 13 ans et
alexis td gallas il serait que d'une
nouvelle vous raconter ça qui quand il
était petit bolide qu'il était sensible
mais pas sentimental
oui c'est très important trouver les
points quand il était petit pendant
qu'ils travaillent y mettait du
sparadrap sur la bouche de first 1 quand
il était petit cran avant kate grand ah
bon bruit
et quand il monte grand candy
travaillait avec jean claude carrière et
vous y mettez du sparadrap sur la bouche
de sacha parce qu'elle était trop
bavarde
alors vous travaillez dans nikita avec
besson et vous vous êtes assez fasciné
par sa recherche du graal ce que vous
appelez de fer recherche du graal oui
oui parce qu'il est obsédé comme tous
les hommes dont nous avons parlé mais
peut être d'une façon parce qu'il est
plus jeune et qu'il appartient à cette
époque dans laquelle nous vivons ça ne
pas détourner ni par la littérature ni
par un art plastique c'est cinéma cinéma
cinémas et quand nous avons travaillé
ensemble j'ai tourné quoi quinze jours
dans les kits à je me suis amusé parce
qu'ils s'amusaient absolument follement
hills et refaire les scènes
je veux me faire un peu comme ça a pu si
on essayait comme ça un peu plus triste
un peu plus gai plus lent plus rapide on
sentait que ça pouvait durer et durer
vous pardonner tout réalisateur
vous appelez ça des particularités pour
pas dire des défauts oui oui y'a pas il
n'ya pas des fonds alors gérant philippe
en un mot j'étais tellement en extase
béate qui m'est arrivé d'oublier mon
texte
c'est embêtant non bah oui et puis
surtout dans le prince ont beau avoir un
trou dans la salle
dans la cour du palais des papes s'est
mis à le vent qui passe gabin me tombait
avec le gamin oui mais moi j'aime tous
les hommes avec lesquels je travaillais
une aventure avec lui oui dans le grisbi
ah oui dans le vieux et puis j'ai fait
un film alors la suite ah j'oubliais le
titre l'idée non pas du tout ce qui
l'était catcheur lino ventura avant oui
je sais